I was very proud to work on portal I had
been a fan of the company valve for some
time I'd played their games before so
when they asked me if I'd be interested
in running music for them I said
absolutely without a without hesitation
and you know I played an early version
of that game and like the rest of the
Internet I had seen the the teaser
trailer for it and so I was excited
about it and I knew it was gonna be cool
and then you know when we came up with
this idea to have one of the characters
sing a song at the end basically put a
almost it's almost a musical theater
number in the game you know it seemed
fun and and awesome but also like maybe
it wasn't such a good idea and it wasn't
gonna work out but um you know even when
we were finished I think we were we were
all kind of happy with the results but
we didn't know how people are gonna
respond to it and of course you know
everybody just went crazy which was
extremely gratifying
you know I for me you know I grew up
playing video games and there's that
there's that thing that happens at the
end of the game in particular game that
has a long story arc to it or a kind of
quest to it you get to the end and you
you're little you're a little sad you
know because you've been existing in
this world and you've been participating
in this story and then suddenly it's
over and you know that there's no new
that thing anymore you're done with new
that thing you know and so you know I
took I took inspiration from from that
you know I the sort of the parade of all
the characters at the end of Super Mario
Brothers you know it's a celebratory
moment too but there's also a little bit
of sadness when you sort of sit back and
and watch the credits because damn it
you've earned it you know so I wanted it
I wanted it to be like that and you know
it's funny I my my daughter and I
my daughter who is 5 we just played a
game called a boy and his blob which is
a long sort of platforming game where
you you have a friend is a blob of stuff
and if you feed him certain jellybeans
he'll turn into different tools that you
can use to solve puzzles and so she and
I played that together and you know for
weeks and weeks you know I watched her
sort of figure out how to play a video
game which was awesome and then you know
at the end we finished the we killed the
last bad guy and the credits started to
roll and she started to cry and I like
oh I know I know exactly I know exactly
I know exactly how you feel because
that's you know this is what it is at
the end of the game so you know I'm I'm
of course pretty pleased with how portal
turned out and how it was received and I
still think it's a terrific game you
know even leaving aside the song you
know it's just such a brilliantly drawn
character that you get to know in GLaDOS
throughout the game and and you come to
you come to really love her and
understand her by the end even though
she's trying to kill you and I think
that's a you know that's a remarkable
achievement in in any medium so
I do you know there was roger ebert
actually wrote a blog post recently
where he he declared his opinion which
is that video games can never be art and
there were you know immediately there
were thousands and thousands of comments
from people disagreeing with him
and you know i won't get into the
details of his of his argument i think
we just have a fundamental disagreement
about the semantics which you know
immediately makes it a really
complicated issue to discuss but yeah i
certainly think that games are video
games are a young medium and only
recently have we been able to have the
kind of video and audio experiences that
are strong enough to really carry a
story and create a vision and and and
all that stuff although you know that
said i think there's a you know the the
trend of of art games i think is really
interesting games that are playable but
not not really not really winnable you
know they are their experiences and
there are artworks you know I'm thinking
of there's a game called passage that is
really just a sort of metaphor for for
going through life and making choices
and ultimately dying and it's it's
really very powerful it takes a few
minutes to play it's not a very
interesting game to play and then at the
end of it you it moves you and you know
if that's not art I don't know I don't
know what is
um I have not started working on it yet
but yes I have had some discussions with
valve about writing music for for portal
2 and it does look like it's going to
happen I don't think I'm allowed to talk
about any details but I have seen some
demo II stuff of the new game and
there's a lot of cool stuff in it and
you know I'm really really pleased to be
dipping back into that universe again I
think the game is going to be fantastic
I'm again I am also terrified about that
because it's it I don't think there's
any way we can follow up on the success
of portal 1 but you know we'll do our
best